At the time it was made, Saw 7 was to be
the final chapter of the Saw franchise,
and in honor of the series it would bring
back old characters, old locations, old music,
old tricks and old traps. But I just want to know
what happened to the old hot dog guy from Saw 2?
We’re gonna get into all the Saw series
callbacks that are in this movie (and there
are a lot of them), but first, let’s talk
about something new. For the first time,
the opening trap takes place out in public
during the day rather than in a dark,
abandoned cellar of some kind. The characters
find themselves in a display window for
a store called Welthammer. Judging by the
style, this is 1000% where FoundFlix shops,
and in one wide shot we see their
slogan, “Renovating Your Life”,
which I think fits nicely with the goal of Jigsaw,
to rehabilitate the lives of his test subjects.
He was way ahead of his time, teaching
young men the dangers of getting simped.
“The same woman has played each of you for a fool,
manipulating your love for her and causing nothing
but pain.”
“She is toxic.”
Now I saw James’s Kill Count, and upon mention of
the word toxic he put a Britney Spears
soundbite so uh… I’m gonna one up him.
🎵 Toxicity - System of a Down 🎵
And honestly, this is probably the
happiest ending of any Saw trap,
and Hoffman retires to his new hideout,
which contains a variety of secrets.
Welcome to Things You Missed. I tend to refer
to the original 7 Saw movies as “The Saw Saga”,
so here we are at the end of it. The Saw movies
were longtime kings of the October box office.
There was even a marketing phrase that went,
“if it’s Halloween, it must be Saw.” But Saw
6 was actually beaten in 2009 by Paranormal
Activity, and Saw 6’s director, Kevin Gruetert
was supposed to direct Paranormal Activity
2, which would go head to head with Saw 7.
So the studio said… “You know what?
You’re contractually obligated to do
another movie for us, you can’t do Paranormal 2.”
So Kevin Gruetert said “fine, but I’m gonna change
a bunch of stuff last minute and it’s gonna suck.”
“Fine.” “FINE!” “..........But
were shooting it in 3D.”
Hoffman’s hideout is filled with the stuff we’ve
come to expect to find in a Jigsaw workshop:
Billys, piggies, and mannequins. This mannequin
could be prototype of the harness
that Dina wears in the opening trap.
I’ve pointed out clues about the location
of the Saw saga throughout this series,
and most evidence has pointed to the setting
being a fictional version of Newark, NJ,
while others seem to point towards New York City.
The newscast mentions a storm hitting the East
Coast, but Hoffman’s drivers license looks more
inspired by a New York ID, unlike the license
plate which seem more New Jersey. One thing’s
for sure, that’s gonna be a disgusting omelet.
Also, the money he’s putting in his bag at the end
of the movie says Bank of New York
on it, so take that as you will.
The TV mentions seven survivors found from the
Zoo Game of the last movie, but by my count we’ve
only got six: Pamela Jenkins, Brent Abbot, Tara
Abbot, Addy, Emily and Shelby. Unless they’re
counting Jill Tuck, but she wasn’t actually
part of that game so… I don’t really get that.
Another point I mentioned about the location
in the last video is that the TV station
starts with W, which signifies a channel
in the Eastern United States, whereas K
means Western states. The TV station where Bobby
Dagen has his talk show appearance is KWGA-TV,
so I think he filmed the interview in another city
shortly before traveling back across the
country for the survivor support group.
The host actually does mention
that he’s on a national tour.
“Welcome back. We’re live with
Bobby Dagen, whose national tour,
S.U.R.V.I.V.E: My Story of Overcoming
JIGSAW, rolls into town this weekend.”
She’s also got a buddha statue on her set,
just like the one seen by John’s deathbed
in Saw 3. But what’s more interesting
about this talk show is the title of it:
Daybreak with Donna Evans. The previous year,
there were a number of horror movies distributed
by Lionsgate, one of which was called Daybreakers,
which was a pretty good vampire movie with
one part that just… I’m gonna roll the clip.
*hilarious scream*
*laughing*
Another thing that’s very interesting
about this, and completely unplanned,
is that Daybreakers was directed by Peter
and Michael Spierig, who would eventually
be the ones to bring the Saw series back from
the dead, pun intended, in 2017 with JIGSAW.
This is the point where Saw 7 does another
thing the series has never done before and
shows us a dream sequence, which I’m not that
crazy about because the series has been kind
of grounded in reality for the first 6
entries, so why are we doing this now?
What I do find interesting about this
trap, which is called The Pain Train,
is it’s possible connection to Spiral. We see
the signature Jigsaw spiral on this device,
and although this is just a nightmare,
maybe Jill had this bad dream based off
a real trap idea that she found in
his workshop. Spiral’s not out yet,
but based on the trailer, it does look
like there’s something involving a train.
I’m also glad they brought back the METAL for this
scene. We haven’t had a good
metal Saw trap in a while.
🎵 Metal Music 🎵
Also, I can’t show it for
multiple obvious reasons,
but after she’s torn in half by The Pain Train,
you can just see her boobs for half a second.
Just hanging there on opposite sides. Didn’t
notice that the first couple times I watched it,
but feel free to pop the Blu-Ray
if that’s your thing, I guess.
Last episode I pointed out how she still
had pictures of John in her apartment,
which could be used to explain why she was
willing to carry out his plan, because it
looks like there are still some feelings there.
She’s got a shot of him by her bedside too,
and she still sleeps on one side of the bed. This
movie is all about her trying to stay safe from
Hoffman but, I don’t think wine and pills are the
best way to go when you’re trying to stay alive.
After this, there’s a time skip
forward to the next Jigsaw trap,
and the main victim is this guy
named Evan. If he looks familiar,
it’s because he’s played by Linkin Park
frontman Chester Bennington. Apparently
one of the guys in his band lived next door to
Saw producer Mark Burg and the rest is history.
Evan and his friends would not
make it out of this trap though,
and so, would not get to participate
in the Jigsaw Survivors Support Group,
which contains a whole bunch of cameos from
characters who survived in movies past,
and many of them look different than
they did during their initial tests.
The Jigsaw Survivor Support Group
brings together those who managed
to escape their tests dating all the
way back from the first Saw to Saw 7.
They include Lawrence Gordon, the
doctor from The Bathroom Game in Saw;
Scott Mallick, the arsonist of the Fatal
Five in Saw 5;
Simone, the loan shark from the Pound of Flesh Trap in Saw 6;
Addy, the
receptionist of Umbrella Health in Saw 6;
Emily, one of the policy reviewers in from
Umbrella Health in Saw 6;
Tara Abbott, the widowed mother in Saw 6;
Brad and Ryan
from the opening of Saw 7;
Bobby Dagen, who was only pretending to be a victim to sell
books
and a new character named Sidney.
There are a couple of other new characters as well,
though we never learn their names or stories.
There are other known survivors who are
missing from this group. From Saw 1 we have Jeff Ridenhour, Alison Gordon and Diana Gordon.
From Saw 2, there’s Daniel Matthews.
From Saw 3, there’s Corbett Denlon.
From Saw 4, there’s
the teacher’s wife, Morgan.
From Saw 5, we have Brit Stevenson.
From Saw 6 there’s Brent
Abbot, Pamela Jenkins and Shelby.
From Saw 7, there’s Joan, the woman who inspired Bobby
Dagen.
And from Jigsaw, there’s Logan Nelson.
We get to see the story of the new character,
Sidney. The reason she is tested is not
clear, but the theme of the trap seems to be…
I don’t know, gardening themed? We’ve got
lawnmowers, potted plants, some Keemstar
merch. You really gonna start killing people
for not mowing the dang old lawn Jigsaw?
She gets into it a little bit with the one-handed
wonder, Simone. We saw her in the last movie
explode at Hoffman for asking if she learned
anything from Jigsaw’s test, and this time she
blows up on Sidney for suggesting that the trap
was the best thing that ever happened to her.
“That’s a bunch of bull****. He had to die for
you to leave him? You want to know the best thing
that happened to me after having to cut off my
own arm? Is handicap parking at the DAMN MALL.”
*clapping*
Good job Simone.
Girl always stands her ground. The location where the group meets is inside
of a church. I’ve talked in the previous
videos about the religious undertones
of Jigsaw’s following. The survivors
of his tests become his followers, and his
rules serve as his commandments to them.
So them meeting inside of a church is
an interesting decision in that respect.
And I know I’ve said it before, but Gordon’s
part is so hilarious. I can’t not play it.
“I’m sure I speak for everyone here when I
say how grateful we are to be part of your
promotional DVD.”
*clapping*
So the Metropolitan Police Department couldn’t
get it done, the FBI couldn’t get it done, so now,
with the new Jigsaw being Hoffman, a police
officer, it falls on Internal Affairs,
the division that investigates crimes committed
by the police. Which raises the question,
who investigates IA? Because I
have a crime to report: Gibson,
you made this way too obvious. Did
you have to make it that obvious?
The main game of Saw 7 follows Bobby Dagen as he
tries to save those close to him as punishment
for faking that he was a Jigsaw victim. His
wife watches his struggle on the monitor.
“What’s going on? WHAT’S GOING OOONNNN??!”
Like, do you really not know? Your
husband wrote a book all about this,
do you seriously not know
what’s going on here?
We see the moment Bobby had the idea to write his
book after seeing the story of
a survivor of one of the traps.
“It gave me light. That pure moment of absolute
horror gave me light and as wrong as it may seem
I’m better for enduring it.”
It’s interesting the way she words it,
that it gave her light, because John talks
about the idea of enlightenment for this
test subjects from the very first movie,
and lights were used as a symbol of
this at the beginning of each film.
As Bobby continues down the IKEA path, he
discovers his own motivational phrases being
mockingly displayed against him. We know this
because the title of his book is an acronym,
S.U.R.V.I.V.E. We can’t really see the text on the
book cover, but if we take the first letter of the
phrases graffitied on the psychiatric hospital
in the order they appear, it spells out the
word survive. Put it all together and you get:
START your life anew, UNDERSTAND your problems,
REDEFINE your priorities, VERIFY
your self worth through commitment,
IGNORE your detractors, VALUE your loved
ones, EMBRACE every day as if it is your last.
There’s also a theme that connects each room
throughout the game. Bobby’s associates enable
his behaviour by knowingly supporting his lie.
Throughout the series, there have been many
examples I’ve pointed out of John pulling ideas
from Asian culture, and the traps in this game
connect to a Japanese legend known as The Three
Wise Monkeys, a 17th century pictorial maxim
meant to teach its audience not to ignore when
they see someone commit a sin. The three monkeys
are Mizaru, translating to “see not”; Kikazaru,
which means “hear not” and Iwazaru, “speak not”.
In the tape for each of the games in
Bobby’s trial, Jigsaw mentions that
his associates must speak no evil, hear
no evil or see no evil in order to pass.
The first room contains a
trap for his publicist Nina.
“She has been your publicist for years, knowing
your lies but choosing to speak no evil.
She has been richly rewarded for her words, but
today she will be rewarded for her silence.”
And the trap literally threatens her ability
to speak, and help spread Bobby’s lies,
by threatening to impale her throat if she makes
too much noise before he retrieves the key.
This is one of the most frustrating traps
ever, because she hears the tape too,
she knows she’s not supposed to scream, and yet…
*SCREAMING*
I mean is she that dumb? Does she have a
deathwish? Why does she keep screaming?
“Why wouldn’t you just shut the ****
up? You just needed to shut up!”
Thank you! Nina was the dumbest victim ever!
The next room contains a trap
for Bobby’s lawyer, Suzanne.
“Before you is your lawyer, who
swore an oath of ethics but chose
to see no evil in order to benefit herself.”
If Bobby could not save her, she
would be forced to see no evil,
because she’d be impaled in the face with more
spikes, probably making her look like a
Minecraft creeper. And like the last game, why
is she screaming through the entire thing? The
dude’s obviously trying to help you, just
shut up for a minute and let him focus.
I’m having a hard time feeling bad for
anyone who’s died in this movie so far.
The third room, by default is the “hear no evil”
room, and contains Bobby’s best friend Cale.
“Across from you is your closest friend. He
knows all your sins, but he acts as though
he hears no evil. Today what he hears will
be the difference between life and death.”
So Bobby has to guide him across the
room using only audible commands.
I mean I would have just told him to stay put,
gotten on all fours and taken the key to him,
which would have been way faster and safer but…
I’m starting to think Bobby’s not the smartest.
But as this game is going on,
the search for Hoffman continues,
and while this email sent to Gibson’s
office only appears on screen momentarily,
there is a lot of info we can pull from it.
Hoffman sends a DVD to Gibson’s supposedly
secret safehouse. The disk is named
Sc57_VHS_edit_4x3. I wish I could say this was a
callback to the first movie where we saw the label
that says “Saw bathroom set”, and that by doing
this they are bringing the series somehow full circle,
but this is kind of inexcusable seven
films in seven years type of stuff.
With the location of the safehouse compromised,
Gibson decides to move Jill to a
holding cell in the police station for
safety. He comes in to ask her a question,
interrupting her reading this blank book.
“Do you know this guy?”
Hoffman sends another video, this time over email,
and if we pause on this screen
there are a few things to note.
The most recent email is obviously from Detective
Hoffman, but the one before that is from Sorin
Popescu. Those of you who’ve been following
all my Things You Missed in Saw episodes will
remember that Sorin is the first assistant
art director of these movies, but his name
has appeared as an easter egg in Saw 5 and Saw
6, so I’ve been piecing together a backstory for
him. Based on the previous appearances of his
name, we determined he was a doctor from Norway
who was a victim of a crime while visiting the
US. Seeing as how he’s now sending files to Matt
Gibson of Internal Affairs, I would have to say
the crime committed against him must have been
committed by the police. Maybe he was subject
to some of Eric Matthew’s police “brutality.”
The other guy emailing Gibson is Brent
McGillivray. This is the first time we’ve
seen that name and he’s credited as a first
assistant art director and set designer.
In the other column here we can
see Hoffman’s email address. Now
I know there is a lot of debate in the Saw
fandom on whether or not Hoffman is alive,
so why don’t we just send
him an email and ask him?
To: m hoffman @ metro dot pol
Mark, I just wanted to email you to confirm
whether or not you are, in fact, still alive.
Please email me back if you are not dead. Thanks,
I’ll let you guys know if he gets back to me.
Below Hoffman’s email address, we have the date:
March 12th. Saw 5 and Saw 6 took place in July
2006, and we can assume Jill’s dream took place
in the winter on account of all the snow, so
the March 12th date puts us in early 2007,
which checks out nicely with the 2007
calendar we saw at the auto body shop.
Under that we see Gibson’s email address.
Might as well send him something as well.
M gibson @ metro dot pol
Hey Gibson, I know you're now dead, but
I just wanted to say, you were the only
good cop besides Kerry, and she's also
dead. Rest in peace man, rest in peace.
The email content reminds Gibson of an event
from their past where Hoffman saved his
life by mercilessly shooting a junkie.
“I had no choice but to report
Hoffman for “Brutality.”
They end up finding the secret room in the
auto body shop behind the bathroom mirror. This
might be a reference to Candyman, where the two
apartments are connected by a mirror in a similar
fashion, but could also just be a callback to
Saw 5 and the hidden doorway seen in that movie.
They end up finding Hoffman and John’s notes
about the victims for this game, and they
give us a little bit more insight into how John’s
assistants are always able to find and kidnap the
vicitms so easily. There are detailed notes about
their daily routines, their personal information,
where they can be found; even specifics about
their alarm codes and computer passwords.
Bobby’s final test is to do what he lied
about having done in his book by impaling
his pecs with meat hooks and hoisting himself
up. This has got to be the dumbest trap yet.
Just put your feet on the smooth part of
these hooks and pull yourself up that way.
Or just climb the chain or something. This is
literally the dumbest way to go about this.
Naturally, he fails, and as a result, his
wife has to pay the price for reason. It
doesn’t really say why she was a part
of this, but I think we can assume it
has something to do with the fact that she
was only interested in him for his fame.
Her punishment is a modern day version of The
Brazen Bull, a torture device / execution chamber
depicted in renderings from Ancient Greece in
which a person was placed inside of a hollowed
bronze bull and a fire was ignited underneath,
thereby roasting the person, but not the way
I might roast my opponents in Rocket League,
but actually roasting them, like the way you
might roast your shwarma before sticking it in a
Pita and drizzling over tahini sauce, to stay on
the Mediteranean theme of this trap.
The Saw version of the Brazen Bull seems to be more shaped like a Brazen Pig,
keeping up with the theme of pigs that has come up time and time again in this franchise.
Like the
Pendulum Trap from from the fifth movie, there
is some debate as to whether or not the Brazen
Bull actually ended up becoming a real thing.
And that’s the last we see of
Bobby Dagen. I guess he’s most
likely still alive. I’d personally
like to see him write another book.
The police realize that Hoffman
tapped into their security system.
“He’s been watching us the whole time.”
I think it’s not so much that
he’s a hacker, but more that
he’s a cop and I guess they forgot
to revoke his access after realizing
he’s bad. Or maybe he actually is a
hacker, who even knows at this point?
Hoffman had hidden himself in one of the body
bags being transported back to the station,
and the first person he encounters is the
coroner. This is meaningful for Hoffman,
because this was the same guy that discovered
that a different knife was used to cut the
jigsaw piece from Seth Baxter, which is
what led to Hoffman getting caught by
the FBI in the previous movie, forcing
him to hide out for 8 months.
He then goes on a rampage, taking out nearly the
entire police station in pursuit of Jill Tuck.
“I’ve been looking for you.”
If we pause as Jill grabs something to defend
herself with, it looks to be part of a nail file
kit. There’s also an article about lowering
the cost of healthcare by moving to Canada,
though I guess that would be
more appropriate in Saw 6.
She’s able to get away, if only temporarily,
and scrambles to hide in the evidence room,
and in the background of nearly
every shot in there we can spot,
old traps, newspaper headlines, design
sketches and more Things You Missed.
After following the journeys of countless law
enforcement officers in their conquest to put an
end to the Jigsaw killings, it is only fitting
that we near the conclusion of the Saw saga
by finally paying a visit to the main evidence
room, but fans may choose to see it as more of
a shrine to almost everything we have come to
know over the course of this 7 movie journey.
As Hoffman comes in and turns on the lights
there is a collection of newspaper clippings
and magazine covers, including this
one, Police Injured During Jigsaw Raid,
which details the beginning of the invasion at
Wilson Steel Plant from the beginning of Saw 2.
On the top shelf of this thing you’ll see the
Head Cage that we saw in John’s workshop in
Saw 2, but was never used. From that same
workshop, is this photo on the back wall,
which corresponds to the face mask trap that
I theorized to possibly be an early version of
the Oxygen Crusher. And this giant clamp was
the device that crushed the janitor, Hank.
Just imagine the whole thing rotated so
the clamps are reaching out towards us.
Up in the corner may be the
oxygen tanks used in that trap.
Hoffman also sees a mannequin from the
mannequin factory on Stygian Street in Saw 1,
where John narrowly evaded Sing and Tapp. Another
mannequin is seen on the other side of the room.
There’s also a cart with the scale used in The
Pound of Flesh Trap, the opener from Saw 6.
The headgear from The Pound of Flesh is sitting
on a shelf on the other side of the room, and
the tubes they had to send their offerings down
to reach the scale are sitting behind the desk.
Just beyond the scale is the Hydrofluoric
Acid injection rack from the Rowan Zoological
Institute, also from Saw 6. Also from the zoo,
is the little cage that William Easton had to
put his hand into to determine who lives and who
dies during the infamous Shotgun Carousel Trap.
These big gears appear to be
the components that held up the
giant ice blocks that eventually
crushed Eric Matthews in Saw 4.
Over to the right, behind the wall we
can see part of The Rack from Saw 3.
In front of that wall is a
cage containing four shotguns,
these are the Quadruple Shotguns
that got Detective Sing in Saw 1.
The chair that Hoffman grabs is fittingly,
his chair from the end of the last movie,
that Jill setup to shock him when he sat down.
Of course, who could possibly forget the good old
classics? Hoffman passes on the Reverse Bear Trap
2.0 that Jill left him to die in at the end of the
previous movie and opts for the Saw 1 original.
On the left wall there are more articles
and evidence photos including a very
dapper looking shot of Yung Billy when
he was doing the whole Pete Wentz look,
which is right above the photo of John and Art
Blank at the opening of Gideon Meat Packing Plant.
If you look all the way on the right,
partially obscured by the wall,
you’ll see the Water Cube Trap that
almost drowned Agent Strahm in Saw 5.
I’m not entirely sure about this, because the
lighting is different, but the device seen on top
of the cart on the right here may be the spinal
contraption that Art Blank had to wear during his
test in Saw 4, and these wheels could really be
a number of things, but they may be the device
John used to manipulate the audio in this
tapes, we see it in a flashback in Saw 4.
So that’s the evidence room, and that’s the
Saw saga. I do feel like I may not have gotten
every little thing, so let me know if you
caught any other references in the comments.
The Saw series was thought to be over
after the release of Saw 7 in 2010,
but like many horror icons, Jigsaw
could not be kept off the silver screen,
and the franchise would return with Jigsaw in
2017. Click the video on the left to see what
you might have missed in that eighth installment,
and be sure to subscribe, because I think it may
be time to give that video a revisit and offer up
a few new Things You Missed. Make sure you ring
the deathbell for notifications and I’ll see
you in the next one. Assuming we both survive.
Hoffman never emailed me back so… guess he’s dead.